speaking about the world being uh
completely [ __ ] uh
alex jones turned on q anon i i know
almost
a very tough match they had a rough
marriage they fought it and they fought
it out for years
uh and eventually we just knew someone
was going to leave someone
uh tried to leave him a few months ago
oh so
was he staying at someone else's house
the car wasn't in the driveway
um yeah well the thing about q anon that
makes it a lot of fun yeah
it's kind of a make it up as you go
along i've i'm a drug addict right
so often my lies aren't planned they're
in the moment a lot of what i do on the
podcast a lot you know it's only in the
moment i have an idea what i want to
talk about and i rant and i go
and i've been like stoned and i show up
at home and my parents are like
what's going on there was 50 on the
mantle now it's not there
and i'm like well
and i got to make something up on the
spot right i've been
you know are you drinking again no i'm
not and then you gotta have a well you
were gone for two days no one knows
where you were and somebody said you
left your car well i was
well this is i was at a sales conference
and i left my car i flew to phoenix like
i understand what that is q anon is an
ever evolving conspiracy theory where
the events are happening
uh in the past in the present and in the
future it's kind of hilarious every
conspiracy theory is like kennedy
something like that there's a lot of
truth in that or all truth but
at the end of the day it's like you're
looking back from 30 000 feet analyzing
little things that have already happened
q anon is like so i think alex is kind
of like got a little tired of
the constant evolving nature of that
conspiracy theory
so he's not a fan of like the jazz that
it's queuing on so they're not because
they're improvising
they're improvising alex is like hey man
i i was on board a little bit but at the
end of the day it's getting a little
annoying because
it can turn on you eventually you become
part of the conspiracy
right still alex is controlled
opposition that's what they'll say
eventually you because q anon just eats
things
so it's a conspiracy that just eats
things the minute you start to say hey
man maybe that's not
it'll just eat you and go you're in on
it everyone's in on it everyone's a
satanic pedophile everybody
everyone that questions it is uh eating
children and
you go wait a minute that seems
illogical and but now
there's not enough children no there's
not enough and i think q anon's over now
unfortunately uh um because for these
people but i think fortunately for them
they're gonna have to find a new hobby
but i think it's over now because even
the best q anon people now are starting
to go hey man this might not be going
down the way we thought
yeah but they've literally gone as far
as to say that like bob and trump
switched faces
trump's actually still the president
except by this year you have to be a
real
[ __ ] now you got to be real
stupid now it's at the end like when
it was cool like when the epc stuff
happened q and on was like it was party
at queue
yeah and then when the hunter bite
laptop stuff started to happen they were
like dancing
like it's time and then
biden wins and they're like wait whoa
and it's just like it's the day after
the park queueing on if you ever went to
a party in high school or college
queuing on right now is the day after
the party you wake up it's it's it's
12 noon the sun is hitting you in the
face you're hungover there's a stench of
disgusting beer
and cigarettes all over the house you're
like what the [ __ ] happened here yeah i
gotta get out of here
and get a bacon egg and cheese that's
what q anon is they gotta sober up
get out of that house get a bacon egg
and cheese and go man we were [ __ ]
whacked we were high dude i thought
nancy pelosi was eating children for
four years
and that donald trump was gonna put her
in guantanamo bay yeah
wow that was because i mean it's
interesting the people had to do that
after the 60s
they're like yeah i just did a bunch of
acid and i lived in a ranch in malibu
and [ __ ]
everyone i ever saw and they're like i
thought that was the way the world was
gonna go and i
followed some shaman guy some guru who
just wanted to [ __ ] me and
10 other people that were living there
and uh we did that for three years
apparently we never created the utopia
we thought we were going to have
and now i'm back working here you know
at allstate insurance
and we have great policies and we'd love
you to come in the office so we can
break them down for you
it all ends folks all the love all the
[ __ ] ends
but it's fun they had so much fun q anon
was hard to get mad at because they were
this was all they had yeah
and they were fun they were quite good
at it and they were good at it and they
and and and it was a lot of desperate
people but they were also rich
idiots there's also like dumb rich
people and you that
those are like the saddest people in
queue because it's like they should they
have the resources to do other things
yeah but they just
love q they're like i'm just into this
i'm like you're
rich go do something how in curious are
you
go to the amazon go birdwatch i don't
know but there
you know so play golf it's sad but
they're like done now i mean
they're they're oh it's over also you
think this is the uh
i think everything's ending my whole
thing is that trump's out q anon's over
the quarantine's gonna end everything's
gonna go back to
something that's more recognizable i
think that
are you optimistic about the 2021 and
what you what
in certain aspects i have optimism and
then i have
i have short-term optimism and long-term
pessimism
okay meaning that i think in the short
term things can get better i think
long term because there's so many forces
that are out of our control that are
revolving in ways i barely understand
that are carving up society it's going
to be very tough long term
to be completely optimistic like hey
it's going to be great it's going to be
good forever
but short term i think yeah this
quarantine will end things will get
better the economy will get a little
better
uh the constant trump craziness will die
down a little bit
um that's my hope and people can go back
to focusing on things that matter
which is you know the things that are
near you and close to you yeah the
humans around you
humans around you not nancy pelosi
i have my i have uncles who talk about
nancy people i'm like you've never met
her
you'll never meet or shut up yeah and i
i have a belief that this kind of
local love and kindness that you
naturally can have for
human beings that you actually know can
be expanded
at scale through the social networks
that
we use that we build twitter is
currently
failing at that miserably that would be
great but that's if we were able to
increase the love
through the social networks that would
be great it feels very hard too
it's a worthy challenge
you